إنهم يفهمون أن ذلك سيكون له
عواقب إذن بالطبع ما لا يعرفه أحد
هو ما إذا
كانوا على الرغم من تلك العواقب
سيختارون مرة أخرى استخدام
القوات المسلحة ضد أوكرانيا ، وقد
سمع العالم أنك تقول هذه الإجابة الواضحة مرات عديدة ،
هل هم فقط لا يستمعون إليك.
إجابتنا واضحة جدًا ، فنحن
مستعدون للجلوس ومناقشة
الانخراط في
الحد من مخاطر شفافية مراقبة الأسلحة المتوازنة التي يمكن التحقق منها ولكن لا
يوجد مؤشر على استعدادهم
للانخراط في ذلك البئر الذي لا يزال يتعين
رؤيته أه لأن روسيا لم تكن جاهزة
في الاجتماع  اليوم للموافقة على سلسلة
من الاجتماعات ، فلماذا لا
تصدق جيدًا؟ أعتقد أن السبب هو أن
روسيا
بحاجة الآن إلى إعادة هذه المقترحات مرة أخرى
ومناقشتها بشكل تدريجي نظرًا
لوجهة نظر الرئيس بوتين المعلنة
وطول عمره وقوته ليأتي إلى حيث يكون
الحل الوسط عندما يطالب  للحديث عن
الناتو وأوكرانيا والعضوية وحلف شمال الأطلسي
وسحب القوات إلى شرق الناتو
، أوضح الحلفاء
اليوم  ما هي القضايا التي نحن جاهزون للجلوس فيها
ومناقشتها أه أه تقديم تنازلات تحدث
مع الروس حول الحد من التسلح
ومجالات أخرى
أه لكننا أوضحنا أيضًا أننا
لسنا مستعدين للتنازل على سبيل المثال
على حق كل دولة في
تحديد طريقها  الآن الكرة
ثابتة في ملعب الكرملين الآن ، نعم
سننتظر ردهم على
اقتراحنا بالانعقاد في
اجتماع جاد يتناول مجموعة واسعة من
القضايا المهمة للأمن الأوروبي